hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute wieder in der kategorie was koche
ich heute und zwar mache ich heute ein
leckeres hauptgericht so bittel
schweizerisch angehaucht und zwar
geschnetzeltes zürcher art und es gibt
rolf steht dazu also kartoffelrösti und
ich zeige euch jetzt mal kurz die
zutaten das ist jetzt kein original ist
also ich hab so einen gewissen stellen
abgewandelt und deswegen nennt man das
auch geschnetzeltes zürcher aber nicht
züricher geschnetzeltes und ich zeige
jetzt die zutaten und zwar habe ich
sechs und 600 gramm mehlig kochende
kartoffeln
ich hab's also und pfeffer etwas
muskatnuss dann brauche ich das
geschnetzelte 900 gramm kalbsfleisch
dass ich jetzt von der oberschale fünf
schalotten 500 gramm champignons die
habe ich bereits mit einem tuch einfach
bisschen ab geräten drei esslöffel
sojasauce inhalten esslöffel
speisestärke 250 milliliter
und ich habe hier noch 200 gramm sahne
bisschen butter schmalz und petersilie
und zitrone und zwar wird eigentlich
beim originalen schnitzel züricher
zürcher geschnetzelte mit eben auch
weißwein benutzt und man muss halt
kalbsfond benutzen auf weißwein möchte
ich verzichten und kalbsfond den konnte
ich jetzt nicht selber machen und wenn
man den kauf muss man drauf also finde
ich muss mal darauf achten dass man
wenigstens einen ohne
geschmacksverstärker und opa ohne hilfe
extrakte und da ich das nicht gefunden
habe nehme ich eben einfach brühe jetzt
bereit ich zuerst mal die rösti vor und
zwar nehme ich die kartoffeln und
schädel sie erst mal
und ich habe jetzt einfach mehlig
kochende kartoffeln dienten nämlich mehr
stärke und dann haftet es besser
zusammen
man streitet sich eigentlich immer darum
ob man immer ganz hohe kartoffel nimmt
oder ob mark gekochte kartoffel nimmt
und die zahl steht verarbeitet und es
gibt sogar die variante als mischung
also dass man rohe und gekochte nimmt
und die dann zusammen verarbeitet ich
mache das uns einfach ganz wohl und
mache auch gleich zwei zubereitungs
weisen einmal in der pfanne und einmal
im backofen
die kartoffeln waschen jetzt kurz ab und
dann reibe ich sie in feine streifen
die kartoffeln sind jetzt gerieben und
ich wollte euch mal zeigen was beim food
prozessor übrig bleibt das ist nämlich
gar nicht viel
und zwar habe ich jetzt nur diese
kleinen rest also falls ihr euch immer
mal gefragt ob da was übrig bleibt
jetzt gebe ich da noch etwas muskat rein
und pfeffer und salz mache ich erst nach
dem braten damit es einfach nicht brennt
und ich das schön auspacken kann
das lasse jetzt aber kurz stehen bereits
so lange schon mal die anderen zutaten
vor
denn hier bist du einfach erstmal alles
richten und dann geht es gleich ans
kochen und dann geht es auch ganz
schnell
ich freue mich die schalotten da habe
ich jetzt 5 ihr könnt natürlich auch
normale zwiebel neben aber charlotten
sind vom geschmack her ein bisschen
feiner als zwiebeln deswegen nehme ich
jetzt die
die zwiebeln habe ich fein gewürfelt man
sieht es an meinen augen
ich muss gleich rheine und jetzt
schneide ich noch die champignons in
feine scheiben und 1 gehören champignons
nicht in einem original zürcher
geschnetzeltes aber ich finde es auch
ganz gut und außerdem ist es auch so
eine abwandlung deswegen zögert
mit schneidig fleisch noch in feine
streifen
die sollten jetzt auch nicht zu klein
sein damit einfach die streifen später
schön saftig bleiben
und da müsst ihr darauf achten dass sie
das fleisch wer also gegen die faser
schneidet dann wird nämlich schön zart
also hier sieht man gut diese fasern und
quer heißt jetzt einfach ich schneide es
nicht so also mit der faser sondern
gegen die phase als es so
hab ich alles vorbereitet und kann jetzt
das ganze auspacken und zwar welches mit
rösti beginn und dann parallel das
geschnetzelte machen
er beziehe zwei pfannen eine etwas
flachere eine etwas tiefere und ich
brate das ganze jetzt in etwas butter is
also butterschmalz weil es einfach nicht
verbrennt wenn ihr jetzt butter nehmt
wegen dem tollen geschmack dann
verbrennt es eben dann nehmt lieber
ansonsten falls er kein butterschmalz
hab einfach sonnenblumenöl zum beispiel
gebe ich das hier in die pfanne
jetzt zeige ich erstmal die variante in
der pfanne und dann noch im backofen
können wir einfach entscheiden wenn sie
ihr nehmen wollte so jetzt nehme ich mit
dem eis portionierer diese
kartoffelmasse eindrücken
es können mal einen großen rollstuhl
machen ich mache jetzt aber lieber
mehrere kleine gibt es hier rein und
jetzt am besten mit so einem
pfannenwender flach drücken
und jetzt dürfen die rösti so von jeder
seite etwa 67 minuten bräunen ist auf
jeden fall die hitze auf etwa mittlerer
hitze stellen das ist einfach schön
langsam gehen kann die kartoffeln gar
werden
und daneben auch knusprig werden jetzt
bereite ich noch das backblech vor als
bestellt die zweite möglichkeit
und zwar nehme ich wieder mit dem eis
portionierer die masse auf hab da halt
immer gleichmäßige portionen dann setzt
sich das hierhin drückt auch flach und
dann bestreite ich das ganze mit
flüssigem butterschmalz also ich mach
jetzt gleich ein bisschen mehr
butterschmalz für sich eine panne und
dann spreche ich das drüber
und die kommen jetzt bei 210 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 15 minuten in den
ofen nach acht minuten muss ich sie
einmal wenden und dann werden sie fertig
gebacken und der vorteil ist eben ich
kann sie in den ofen stecken und muss
dann nicht mehr drauf aufpassen auf die
rösti müssen jetzt aufpassen in der
zwischenzeit schon als geschnetzelte
machen und zwar habe ich jetzt hier auch
etwas butterschmalz und pfanne das ganze
in der praxis des fleisches tanzkurs
ganz scharf an
jetzt nehme ich die heraus sie dürfen
wirklich nur ganz kurz angebraten werden
und am besten ist es wenn ihr das
fleisch auf 23 mal antrat und dann raus
nimmt dann hab da einfach nicht die
gefahr dass die pfanne zu kalt wird und
das fleisch gekocht weil es soll
wirklich scharf angebraten werden
und da kommt es später noch mal mit in
die fresse jetzt gebe ich noch mal einen
esslöffel butter schmalz in die pfanne
dann kommen da die zwiebelwürfel mit ein
jetzt schaltet ein bisschen die zu runde
mittlerweile kann man hier auch direkt
wenden
die 72 minuten glasig dünsten
jetzt gebe ich die champignons dazu und
dünstet die auch noch mal eine minute
mit
jetzt streicht die stärke drüber die
sorgt dafür dass die soße etwas gefunden
wird und dann jetzt direkt mit der brühe
ablöschen und an deiner stelle würde
jetzt auch der weißwein mit dazu kommen
es gebe ich auch hier direkt die sahne
mit rein und stelle den herd herunter
und dann kann das einfach so ein
bisschen in vier bis fünf minuten
reduzieren
die soße sitzt fertig da habe ich jetzt
den herd ausgestellt und jetzt kann ich
das salzen und pfeffern müsste einfach
abschmecken und ich gebe jetzt noch erst
noch kein salz dazu denn es kommt bei
mir ja noch bissl sojasauce wird rein
jetzt kommt hier das fleisch wird damit
dazu und jetzt darf die soße auch nicht
mehr kochen sondern das fleisch muss
einfach nur noch hinziehen dann wird es
schön zart und wird eben nicht sehen und
es kann nicht so etwa fünf bis acht
minuten ziel in der zeit mache ich die
rollstuhl fertig und die petersilie habe
ich hier bereits fein gehackt und dann
können wir gleich anrichten wenn alles
fertig ist
so ich will jetzt fertig und kann
anrichten
der morast darf gleich probieren der
stern von stadler wollte auch ruhig ein
bisschen mehr sein
also die soße könnt ihr nach eurem
belieben gerne auch etwas dicker
einreduzieren lassen
ich möchte jetzt nicht ganz so dick kam
auch mal schön brot tunken
diese sollte auch ganz gut etwas reis
dazu passen aber typischen stade de
suisse noch die kommen ja etwas länger
reduzieren was man etwas länger kochen
lassen sie mich hier noch ein bisschen
stolz über die rechte dann kommt noch
petersilie übers geschnetzelte und damit
dass das ganze nochmal abrundet noch ein
spritzer zitronensaft ganz leicht und
dann da zu probieren
die rechte im backofen die waren
übrigens nicht ganz so knusprig ich
glaube es in der cad wie die aus der
pfanne also ich finde die aus der pfanne
etwas besser wenn man sich die arbeit
übrigens sparen möchte und die ganzen
kleinen rushdies machen möchte kann auch
einen großen machen und den später wie
so ein kuchen verteilen weil es endlich
mal größte ist wirklich klasse sind
gutmenschen spreche die sauce ist auch
richtig toll dass von der c parteien
sehr gut und es war jetzt wirklich auch
ein sehr schnelles rezept muss vor eben
nur wenn man alles schneidet alles gut
vorbereiten und dann hat man eigentlich
in etwa einer halben stunde ein sehr
leckeres gericht
also ich bin kein fleisch esse aber die
rüstig sind ja so genial
es gibt es öfter mal schließt ja mir das
rezept nach machen wollt geht auf salehs
blog.de da steht noch mal alles ganz
genau
wir lassen uns schmecken bevor das essen
kalt wird und viel spaß beim nachkochen
wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
biss dann schwingen die schnecken wie
die kartoffelchips wirklich wie
kartoffelchips besser